hello everybody hi it's time for the
giveaway yes absolutely it's time to do
the raffle for the free t-shirt giveaway
now this is the t-shirt in question this
is a t-shirt that you may be winning
today it actually is really nice it fits
well I was kind of worried about that
the construction might be shoddy but it
fits well this is a size medium for
reference if you win or you want to get
a show on your own yeah the design seems
pretty sturdy it doesn't seem like
something that's gonna crack overtime
yeah I'm really happy with the way
they've turned out so I hope you'll
enjoy it if you win and if you don't win
that's okay they're available at the
t-shirt sure alright so I'm actually
really happy to do this for you guys in
the drawing the buckets right here and
it seems like a smaller pile of names is
they almost seem spindly but that's
because I cut them smaller and so
there's actually like there's actually I
think about 580 names in here they're
just cut smaller so there's a lot of
them it just doesn't seem like it but
anyway compared to the other bucket of
names is not quite as impressive I know
I know but this just made it easier for
me to write it smaller like that but
anyway that's another thing I just
wanted to say how grateful I am that you
guys are helping me out and trying to
grow the channel by sharing and you can
obviously see the impact that you guys
have made it's been astonishing the
growth we've had in just week because
need I remind you that exactly a week
ago we just hit 20,000 and we're as of
this recording at twenty two thousand
eight hundred and forty eight
subscribers that's two thousand eight
hundred and forty eight subscribers in a
week in one week that's insane for a
channel of our size and it's it's all
thanks to you guys and I mean if if you
guys feel that you believe in my channel
and you believe in this channel and you
believe
in the community that we're building
sharing is the best way to grow it
telling all your friends strapping them
to chairs holding their eyes open while
you force them to watch my videos that's
the best way to get the message out
there yes Tom
markiplier says tie your friends to
chairs and make them watch my videos
that's the good stuff but seriously it
helps more than you know because when I
first started this channel and any
advice that I would give to other
channels out there trying to get started
it's a ground war it's grueling work
it's hard because for one no one is
looking for your videos no one knows who
you are if you're starting from scratch
like I did it's it's brutally hard and
I'll admit that when I started out I did
I did an unbelievable amount of work on
my own just trying to get my name out
there not trying to be annoying I'm not
saying I went onto other channels and
commented hey check out my stuff or did
anything like that I just tried to get
involved in the community and thankfully
that got the word out there also I got
lucky with a reddit thing but that's a
whole nother deal that was just pure
unadulterated luck I would never give
that out as advice for anyone to try to
get big just by posting your videos to
Reddit or something like that either way
it's hard but now it's gotten to the
point where you guys are helping me out
instead so thank you so much I'm just
unbelievably grateful that you guys
believe in me and this channel and what
we're doing so um before I get to the
drawing which I'm gonna get I know
you're on pins and needles okay but
anyway thank you guys so much and um
remember there's another livestream this
Sunday starting at 5:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time and the 12 hour 12 hour or
longer charity livestream is coming up
on O the 28th I think it is the 28th
also I picked the charity that I want to
donate to it's called since October is
Breast Cancer Awareness Month I think or
cancer awareness month or breast cancer
awareness month
I picked the charity called living
beyond breast cancer it's one of the
highest-rated breast cancer charities in
the world
like it's it's enormous related no
matter what website you go to there's a
link in the description below to the
charity if you want to check it out for
yourself it's a great charity and I'm
just glad that we're able to do this and
hopefully we'll be able to meet our goal
and even exceed it when we come to
Sundays from now on the twenty
yeah the 28 that is a 28 though 28th
starting at 10:00 a.m. Eastern Standard
Time going till 10:00 p.m. or later or
however long it takes to meet our goal I
won't stop until we make it so thank you
guys so much you are the best and I'm
just happy that I get to wake up every
day and do this it's the greatest
feeling in the world to be able to do
this for you guys so now the main event
that you've all been waiting for I know
you have let's get it I'm gonna pick ten
names
I'm gonna pick ten names and yes there
are 500 names in here it doesn't look
like it but just see that there actually
are quite a few names in here they just
all flattened out okay so shake it up
real good and yes I did not send out
replies to email you sent me but
everyone is in here every single person
who sent me an e-mail the markipliergame
or markiplier at gmail.com got their
name in here so here we go not looking
we're gonna do the same way I'm just
gonna pick 10 10 names and here we go
first name blah blah Jessica Graham
Jessica grayham come on autofocus you
douche now you can read that Jessica
Graham Thank You Jessica Graham for
sharing you just want a free t-shirt
okay mixing it up again and got the
second name let's see
Amy alley Amy alley and kind of read
that sorry that it's not out there you
can kind of see that any alley you are
the second name congratulations you just
want to shirk so third name coming up
mix it up a little more okay we got here
oh and uh baked s Paet anticipate there
it goes about damn time
Anna Spade congratulations you just want
another t-shirt and reminder they look
like this and there are there's a female
fit there's a woman's size also so you
can pick out your size specifically from
there
my fourth name coming up Travis Atkins
Travis Atkins is the new winner come on
Travis Atkins all right you're just
gonna have to take my word on that
so congratulations Travis you just want
a free t-shirt now all of these names
please if you hear your name get called
out please send me an email using the
same email that you sent the the share
with otherwise I won't be able to find
you out there hundreds literally
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
emails so anyway here we go and and the
key and Ian I know my handwriting is
just absolutely awful but that and ey k
ey and Ikki congratulations you won the
fifth teacher six one coming up get
ready I could like filtering messages in
here
you know subliminal messaging just
because you're all hooked and waiting
for the next name here we go number six
F L Johnson F L Johnson so please if you
hear your name please send me an email
using the same email that you sent me
before Eman you know I'll be able to
know it's you because I'll be able to
find you again I'll be searching for
these names but please please please
help me out and send me an email what
you do okay
seventh day me here mmm
dos one two three four mundos one two
three four this is one of those where
someone sent me an email and didn't
provide their name so Boonton dos und OS
one two three four please send me an
email congratulations you just want a
free teacher now number eight oh there's
only three t-shirts left to get away
who's it gonna be who's it gonna be and
it is April the legis April Villa Gus
Apryl villages villa gas villages I
don't know
April Ville Ville a Gus that might be
you either way April congratulations you
just want a free t-shirt so please send
me an email just as a confirmation
number nine the only two left who's
gonna win might as well be you yeah Rick
oh boy oh boy Rick give Ricky Ricky
chronics for Rick Rick give chronics I
know I got the worst handwriting and I
was like speed writing these names here
so sorry about that Rick give KY ro n YX
so thank you and congratulations Rick
give I'm not processing that wrong and
you just want a free t-shirt art there's
only one left only one left I don't want
to take a pause here just a dramatic
pause norms to lets you see good this
sharing and I don't want you guys to
feel like these promotions are cheap i I
really don't they're not just me trying
to get you know more viewership I mean
it does because it's amazingly helpful
when you guys share but I I don't feel
like I've ever needed to have an
incentive for you guys to do that I just
try to make the best videos that I can
and if you guys feel the need you know I
don't ever ask you don't like it or
favorite your anything on whenever I do
a video and do it very sparingly because
you know for certain things I want to
like I really feel like if we all band
together we can really make a impact on
growing the channel but anyway I've been
stalling enough let's get the last one
out here and the final and last final
and last winner of the free t-shirt is
gonna be oh my god mirka klappa Chava
mirka oh god my handwriting is really
bad on that one and it's not gonna
autofocus for
for anything come on Otto folks please
please camera
you're so stupid right now camera please
please camera autofocus on this neighbor
you almost had it you almost had it
get me check it out any second now
really really really you're not gonna do
oh oh oh what what say what say what now
there it is Mirka klappa Chava
so thank you so much you just won the
last free t-shirt so congratulations
that's one - yep that's ten so thank you
guys everyone who shared if you didn't
get your name in I'm gonna do these
giveaways fairly regularly myth not once
a months then once every two months or
so so thank you guys and once I can get
more t-shirts and you know I'm in a
better situation financially myself I
really want to give back to you guys and
I would love I would love to see you at
Comic Con just like a sea of people
wearing my shirt just at least for one
day like one day when we're all meeting
up for the first time I want everyone to
who has a shirt to wear sure so thank
you guys so much for helping out if you
didn't want a shirt sorry thank you for
sharing anyway I wish I could give a
shirt to everyone but I can't if you
wanna buy a shirt and you were holding
up just to see you won one also link in
the description below so thank you guys
so much you are the best fans than I
could ever hope for the 20 I still watch
the 20,000 subscriber dedications video
because it just it means so much to know
that you guys care that much about me as
a person in this channel as a entity or
community or anything like that because
like really we can do so many things
together and I hope that you guys
understand that I'm in this for the long
haul and I'm never going to take
advantage of the popularity that I have
I said that back in when I had 500
subscribers I said it when I had 2000
and then 1000 again and then when I
dropped back bound and you know I I
never want to take advantage of it I
always want to work harder and try to
improve myself for you guys so thank you
all so much for helping
it is really the greatest feeling in the
world to know that I have the support of
so many people and moving forward into
the future with you guys's help and if
you want to keep helping that's
fantastic because the best ways word of
mouth so please keep sharing the videos
even if there's no reward for it because
the reward he is helping this channel
grow into something huge which means
more money for charity more giveaways
bigger better things that we can do
together so thank you guys again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye